amy is in Florida hi Amy welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi thank you for having
me
sure welcome dr. John answer for you
today um I'm trying to figure out how to
talk to and teach my kids about money
without implying anything negative about
their dad who is not great with money
y'all still married no okay
what's that what's the custody
arrangement I happen 60% of the time he
has some 40% of the time okay so tell me
what you want to teach me about money um
you know budgeting their their new
teenagers so college is starting to be
on the horizon as far as you know what
they're thinking of and and you know
teaching them about not getting into
student loan debt and you may be living
at home is a good idea while they go to
school so that they don't get into debt
and just and they're also you know on
the verge of being able to to get a job
and you know their car
I mean wisely budgeting things like that
so here's a couple of important things I
and David love I'd love your thoughts to
number one kids learn by watching you
and so if you want to teach them about
money especially young teens let's say
13 14 year olds in 15 16 year olds you
bring them along when you make your
budget every week or every month and you
help teach them the value of a dollar
and when they get a paycheck you make
sure that they're giving and they're
saving and that they're part of this
process one of the things I dealt with
for years working at universities was
parents whose kid graduated as a senior
and then they started doing the college
math problem right so you you are way
ahead of the game
sitting down your kids saying what's
this gonna cost what's its gonna look
like here's what a dollar amount is just
doing a real math and I love that you're
asking this question so please hear me
badmouth and dad is a losing proposition
for everybody the best way for you to
teach kids about money I know I can hear
that that's why I love this call I can
tell that that's not where you want to
go
but by saying hey don't be like that to
a 16 year old that they're gonna start
to hear a division right the best way is
to say here's how we're gonna do money
when you're at my house - the 60% of the
time yeah but Dad but Dad but Dad yeah I
know but at our house yours when you're
here comment on him mm-hmm or what he
does don't even reference it don't point
negatively or positively to it just
pretend like it's not there at our house
here's what we do
and kids are desperate for boundaries
and so they're not gonna want to do
budgets with you but you're gonna make
them when you're my house we're gonna do
budgets together I mean you're my house
we're gonna we're gonna set aside some
money to give and set aside some money
safe but that's my job as your mom is to
teach you how to become an adult not to
be your friend great you're you're an
adult training school and I'm the
teacher and my job is not to my job is
not to make you feel good my job is not
to build up your self-esteem my job is
not to comb your hair my job is to teach
you how to be an adult so there's some
day you leave a me this this stinks for
you because you're gonna have to live it
right it's gonna be better than a big
fancy speech a one time like you know in
trotty speech you're gonna have to live
it and you're gonna have to be
accountable to yourself and to these
young kids you know I would just say you
know as a single mom when I started
first start doing this honey I was
scared and I want you to see this you
know as a divorced lady this is what I
felt and this is what I was and I want
you to see this and here's how this
works and I want you to see this and you
know more Rachel Cruz says Moore is
caught but then taught it's a great
phrase so you're gonna do great I really
just put not even a reference in them
where they are doesn't matter doesn't
matter what a great question